because I know this is a burden on your
heart right now but Anna is battling
cancer yes how are things going for Anna
right now
um she has had two rounds of chemo she
has her third round next week she has a
scan on Saturday we'll get the results
back on the 9th which is our first day
of chemo this second round has been
really more rough on her she lost all of
her hair and really honestly it's just
been like us we stayed with her during
chemo and then pumpkin and Alana come up
like one day of the week and then
Jessica comes up but honestly it's just
been me and Justin
and Alana Alana pumpkin Josh Jessica and
Eldridge which is Anna's boyfriend that
has honestly been there no none of the
other family has been around
which is sad because at the end of the
day when all this is over with like they
have to live with them decisions so we
can only be there for her so it's just
been me and me Justin and the girls been
there for Anna that your relationship
with Anna today is strong and you're
able to be there for her yes yes can you
inform us of the kind of cancer she is
adrenal carcinoma only 200 people in the
world have it it's a rare cancer it's
very aggressive like one in one year she
got diagnosed um how how it all like
happened is in September in the end of
August she went to the hospital with
back pain she had a cysts on her kidneys
she got it removed that night she had a
biopsy it kind of found she has stage
two they claim they got every bit of it
out she had anything to worry about it
Flash Forward two months later they said
everything was still out Flash Forward
to January they said there was a spot
that they seen Flash Forward to February
um when they she went to Atlanta doctor
when she got done she got diagnosed with
stage four cancer so it happened very
quickly it's in her lungs her liver her
kidneys and her spleen on the left side
and it has moved very rapidly and grew
very rapidly how are spirits
um depends on what day it is like all of
us like honestly
um she sleeps a lot this round her
appetite is going you know she doesn't
want to eat some days yeah but I mean
just like everybody like me like there's
days that I don't know whether to scream
or get mad or get angry or be happy or
you know try to go through the day but
some days you just got to put on that
face and say hey how you doing you know
what I'm saying and some of those days
ain't those days you know so as her mom
and we've had to have those talks that
you don't want to have with your child
and so we've had those talks as a family
too so we all know what the end game is
and we all are prepared for that and um
I mean you're never prepared for it but
but I mean we know what could happen you
know and her children know that which is
sad because she has a 10 and a seven
year old her 10 year old knows more of
it than her seven year old my heart
hurts for you so much June yeah so it's
not easy though I'm sure sorry so I'm
trying to get emotional because I know
that's what I talk about all day
multiple times and you have shared so
much of your life with the world and you
continue to do so
foreign